[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Thank
you for joining us.
My name is Anita Kibunguchy.
And I'm a product marketing
manager for data analytics,
and I'm part of the Google
Cloud Platform group.
And today we have a
really exciting panel.
I'll just do a
quick introduction.
I have Jordan here.
He is an engineering
director for GCP.
And then we have Sudhir.
He's a director of product
management for GCP.
And then we have Matt, who's
the research director, data
platforms and analytics
for 451 Research.
Welcome, gentlemen.
So we'd like to make
this session interactive.
So we have a couple of
mics here in the room.
If you have any questions
or any comments,
then just feel free to
step up and get on the mic,
and then we'll
give you a podium.
OK, so let's get started.
So we know that data is becoming
one of the most valuable assets
for an organization.
It's not surprising
because I feel
like it's one of the
things you've probably
heard over and over
again at this conference.
And we've also heard this term
that says data is the new oil.
So let's start with you, Matt.
How would you interpret
this statement?
And how should customers
think about their data
and also data analytics
in this environment?
MATT ASLETT: Sure thanks, Anita.
And thank you, everyone,
for coming to this session.
Just to give you a
bit of background.
So I'm the research director
for data platforms and analytics
at 451 Research.
We're an industry analyst firm
covering the entire industry.
But the channel, as we
call it, that I look after
covers everything from
backend data platforms
through to frontend analytics
and machine learning, and AI.
And there's a team
of us doing that,
but I'm responsible for
the overall coverage.
So obviously, data
and the value of data
is something we've been looking
at for a number of years.
And I think it's
interesting when
we talk about companies
suddenly sort of discovering
the value of data.
Obviously, this
has been happening
for thousands of years.
Companies, hopefully, have been
making decisions based on data.
But I think what we
see is changing is--
you know, I'm not convinced
about data is the new oil,
but let's not get into that.
But definitely what we do see
is that companies are wanting
to become more data driven.
And could say data is definitely
the fuel for innovation
within organizations,
and particularly--
oh, we're going
for the buzz words.
Let's chuck in digital
transformation as well.
As companies are
looking to transform,
become more responsive
to their customers,
they see that data and
analytics is the fuel that
enables them to do that.
And there's various ways
in which organizations
can take advantage of that.
We'll get into those
in more detail.
So perhaps for now
I'll stop there
and let you come in on
data is the new oil.
Take it where you want to go.
SUDHIR HASBE: No, I agree.
I think as we talk more
and more customers,
they all want to be
more data driven,
have a data-driven
culture, and have
tools that are easy to go
ahead and leverage this data
in day-to-day decision making.
And I think that's the
key thing that I hear
all the time from customers.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, that is so true.
Jordan, anything?
JORDAN TIGANI:
One thing to add--
it's also really key that you
have data that you can trust.
If your data is not
trustworthy and you're
trying to make
decisions based on it,
you're going to make
terrible decisions.
And so sometimes we see like,
there's not a data cleaning
process, or people just don't
really understand the data
well enough.
And if you don't understand
your data well enough,
then you're going
to use it poorly.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Yeah,
I couldn't agree more.
So we know that
consumerization is
one of the key drivers
for growth in data.
And when I say consumerization,
if you think about it,
I mean the number of cat
videos that people are actually
recording, just have
recorded so far,
and are continuing
to record, right?
I mean, if you think about
just the amount of social media
posts, the amount--
I mean, the connected homes
with internet of things.
And I think IDC has an
interesting statistic.
And I think you mentioned
this, Sudhir, yesterday.
I think they are looking at
163 zettabytes of data by 2025.
I mean, if you ask
me, I can't even
imagine how much data that is,
or even just to think about it.
So, Matt, in your
research, just curious,
what are customers looking
for in a data analytics
product with just this
amount of growth in data?
MATT ASLETT: Yeah, well I think
it's actually multiple things.
I mean clearly the volume
of data is significant,
absolutely.
And also, as you mentioned,
data coming from new sources--
oh, actually, organizations
taking advantage of data
that they already
had, but perhaps it
wasn't economically viable
to store and process before.
Hence, we saw the
[? advantages ?]
of Hadoop and NoSQL,
but then Cloud Storage
as well to deal with that.
And then, obviously, IoT is
generating even more data.
But there are other
aspects to it as well.
I mean, we see a lot
of organizations,
there's been a lot of
talk the last couple
of days about
democratization of data,
or at least self-service
access to data,
putting data in the
hands of more business
users and decision makers.
And that is all tied in with
this thing about being data
driven, getting data and
analytics into the heart
of the business, not
just for a select few
within the organization
who make decisions.
So in terms of what
organizations are looking for,
all of that, but as cheaply
as possible [LAUGHS]
and as flexible as possible.
So there's multiple things.
And what I think is--
clearly there's a huge range of
different products and services
that organizations can use
for different purposes.
And it's all then you get into
the nuances of the application.
And I think that's
something, because there's
been so much innovation
in technology
in this space in
the last few years,
sometimes it's
easy to forget, you
have to start with
the business case.
What are you trying to achieve?
And then figure out
which technology
can help you deliver on that.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, good points.
SUDHIR HASBE: Just one more
thing to add here, right?
A lot of customers, when
they look at that number,
like 163, it's like
massive number.
And lot of times
what they think about
is, but my data is
not that big today.
The thing that customers
need is scalable platforms
that can scale to what
data sets they have today
but also ability to scale
over a period of time
when the data grows.
One of the things we are
noticing with all the customers
that have been using, for
example, BigQuery for a while
is, as they start to
see value in data,
they collect more and more.
I think traditional
data warehouses
have this problem where they
all teach people to cleanse,
reduce, aggregate, store.
The whole idea is how do
you not get more data?
It's like you reduce your
costs by aggregating,
pre-aggregating,
cleansing, and all
of that versus what cloud
platforms allow you to do
is collect first and
then analyze, figure out
what's valuable.
And that's where, actually,
the real value comes in.
We have customers
that have literally
had 100x growth in real-time
data they were collecting
from just within a
year to 18 months,
just because they
started getting value out
of a lot of the data sets
that started collecting.
So I would say, from
a product perspective,
focusing on not just
what you need today,
but there are a lot of things
that on-premise systems
restrict you from.
As you think about cloud, it
is the scalable infrastructure
that's there.
So look at how you can leverage
data in a different way.
Bet on scalable platforms that
will allow you to go ahead
and analyze maximum amount
of data that you can collect.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
And so this question
is for you, Jordan, which I
think is very interesting.
Given the massive
amounts of data
and then also given
what we're investing in,
how can you explain how
GCP is thinking about data
analytics and this innovation?
It'd be interesting to just
give the audience a little bit
of a purview into just the
span of products we have
to help with data analytics.
JORDAN TIGANI:
Sure, well I think
one of the things
we want to do is
we don't want to be sort of
just another cloud, particularly
with regard to data analytics.
We have some of the
best infrastructure,
some of the best
technology in the world.
And we want to really
continue to innovate and not
just rest on our laurels.
So, you know, Sudhir
was alluding to,
we don't want to just
be a data warehouse.
We want to be an
amazing data warehouse,
but we also want to
push the boundaries.
Like, what format
is your data in?
Is your data-- all
large data sets
are generally
streaming data sets.
So how do we process the data
in a natural streaming format?
And I think Google has
been a good thought
leader in streaming systems.
And so how do we kind
of drive on that?
Also, how do we take our
advantages in infrastructure
and apply those to things
that nobody else can do?
To give it a good
example of that,
one of the things we
announced yesterday
was the geospatial
features in BigQuery.
And so, Postgres has
some geospatial features.
But one of the things that this
is going to enable you to do
is it's going to enable
you to join a billion data
points in one table
with a billion data
points in another table
to find the points that
are within a certain
radius of each other.
That's a cross join of a
billion by a billion points.
Really nobody can do
that except Google.
And we want to just
continue to apply
those kinds of technologies
and those kinds of smarts
to the things that
we're building.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, absolutely.
SUDHIR HASBE: Just to
add one more thing.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Yeah.
SUDHIR HASBE: To add
one more thing too
that, the other side we
are very focused on also
is just simplifying the
use of these kind of tools
that we are building.
One is scaling is
super important,
but ease-of-use is
really important for us.
Some of the capabilities that
we announced in this week, one
of them was actually ability to
directly-- the new BigQuery UI,
it's snappy and all of that.
But the most
interesting thing there
is you can now run that query
that Jordan was talking about--
with a one click,
you can actually
transfer that into a Data
Studio visualization tool
and actually visualize
it, explore it,
and then create a report out
of it, just with one click.
The other thing you can do is,
with the Sheets integration
that we announced,
you can go in Sheets,
use a BigQuery connector,
fire a similar kind of query,
move the data into Sheets, and
then just use that experience
that all your users are already
familiar with to analyze
that kind of data, visual it.
So ease-of-use is
another side of things,
which is super important for
customers that we focus on.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, and if you
want to learn more
about BigQuery,
we actually have a
showcase in Moscone South.
And I'm actually going to
be there manning the booth
from 12:30 to about
3:00, so we actually
are showcasing the new UI--
so just a shameless plug there.
So thank you so much.
So we're going to switch
gears just a little bit.
One of the things
that we keep hearing
from a lot of our
customers is this idea
of adopting a multi-cloud
strategy, the fact that
no longer are customers just
using one cloud but pretty much
multiple clouds for
different workloads
for different reasons.
And what I'd love to
hear from you, Matt,
in your research, what are you
seeing happen in the industry
and what do you think is
driving this adoption?
MATT ASLETT: Yeah,
it's definitely real
and definitely happening.
What's interesting, as
you said, what's driving
the adoption initially--
so we see-- so amongst
surveying our user base,
it's something like
60% of cloud adopters
are using multiple clouds.
A lot of them have ended
up using multiple clouds
completely by accident
because they've
got different groups in
the organization that
have used different clouds
of different purposes,
Shadow IT have just
spun up things.
And they've sort of
stumbled into this world
of having multiple clouds.
And that's not something
that is necessarily
viable in the long term.
So what we see increasingly
is organizations doing is--
I mean, hybrid cloud
is a term that's
used by different people
for different reasons.
We use that to talk
about companies
actually strategically,
deliberately
using multiple
clouds, specifically
to support a single
application or workload.
And so what we see is
increasingly the organizations
are deliberately doing that.
Actually, of that 60% who
are using multiple clouds,
about 70% are either already
using multiple clouds
to deliver a single
application or are considering
or are working towards that.
And so increasingly,
as I say, that's
just going to be the norm.
And it's then about not
comparing different cloud
providers at a very high
level, very strategic,
looking at different
technologies individually
and how you can
combine them to deliver
a better complete whole.
I mean, a great example of that
would be existing applications,
they're already running up.
They're in one
cloud, but you want
to take advantage of some
vision analysis machine learning
or speech analysis
machine learning.
And it could be a
service on another cloud
is the best choice
for that, so call out
to that for that
very specific purpose
to deliver that combined entity.
So we see many, many
organizations are increasingly,
strategically,
deliberately looking
to do that as opposed to
just sort of stumbling
into the case of
having multiple clouds.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, good point.
Anything you want
to add, Sudhir?
SUDHIR HASBE: Yeah, so the other
thing is multi-cloud is one,
and we fundamentally believe
most of the investments today
for customers are on premises.
And so having this
hybrid scenario, where
most customers will be in a
multi-cloud or on-premises
and cloud pattern.
So this is why if you looked
at the keynotes the first two
days, the focus on being an
open cloud and ability for you
to run your workloads
in multiple clouds,
enabling that kind of capability
is super important for us,
ability to run your
Spark workloads,
whether you're running
on premise, in cloud.
With Beam, what we are
doing, having the same code
that can run with DataFlow but
also run with Spark or Flink,
super important for us.
So we're focusing a lot
on a standardization.
Supporting standard SQL is
part of that whole initiative
for us--
super important.
And also Composer,
which is Airflow,
we're taking open
source technology,
making it available
for customers to use.
And you can use
Airflow or Composer now
to go ahead and
have orchestration
that can span across clouds
on premises, all of that.
And you can centrally manage it.
So, yes, the open
cloud initiative
is key driver because
of the requirement
that customers have that
spans across multiple clouds
and that.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, absolutely.
And then from a
workload perspective,
what are you seeing
customers keep
on prem versus on the cloud?
Is there a difference?
SUDHIR HASBE: Every
customer is different.
People are going to choose
what best technologies
that they need for
their scenarios.
What I am noticing is, from
a Google Cloud perspective,
data analytics, machine learning
is our key differentiator.
And I will see a lot of
times customer first try out
those services on Google and
then they go adopt other areas
and stuff like that.
So I do see a lot of customers
starting with data analytics
on one cloud.
They do have different workloads
that run in different places.
A lot of people run
their operational systems
on premises, maybe
in other clouds.
But for analytics,
machine learning,
I think we have highly
differentiated services.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
I think so too.
I think there's a
lot of announcements.
SUDHIR HASBE: And that enables
them to leverage these things.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, absolutely.
MATT ASLETT: Could
I just add to that?
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Yeah.
MATT ASLETT: Yeah, I think
one of the things we're
increasingly seeing,
obviously, as you said,
the vast majority
of workloads still
run on premises, particular
data and analytics workloads.
But what we've seen in
the surveys that we do
is we look at which are the
most popular applications
or workloads in the cloud.
Obviously database and
analytics are widely popular
applications.
So they were always
there or thereabouts.
But they were always somewhat
further down the list.
In the last couple of years,
they've been increasing.
And now I think the last one we
did at the start of this year,
databases was number
one, analytics
was number two, as
you would expect,
given the wide adoption
of those workloads.
But it does speak to,
I think, the maturity,
the increasing maturity
of adoption in relation
to the cloud.
But you're right.
A key point is there
are a huge amount
of workloads that will either
remain on premises or will be--
we tend to think about
lifting and shifting workloads
to the cloud.
And actually, most of the
time that doesn't happen.
It's about refactoring
or redesigning
the applications for the
new version of that running
in the cloud in a
modern architecture,
taking advantage of
newer capabilities.
So we see a lot more
of that going on.
And so, in some ways,
it will take a long time
for some of the changes
to become obvious,
because a lot of those workloads
will continue on premises
and slowly be retired.
And so, yeah, the shift is--
it's a fundamental
shift, but it's actually
happening, in some
cases, relatively slowly.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, and I think--
JORDAN TIGANI: Can I
add one thing to that?
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, of course.
Go ahead, Jordan.
JORDAN TIGANI:
Just, in terms of,
you mentioned that
lift and shift is not
necessarily something
that people are doing
and they're not starting with.
I think what we often see
is people have a problem,
and that problem may not be
their central data warehousing
or database team.
But it may just be a team that
is not getting the numbers they
want fast enough.
And so they pull
that into the cloud.
And then people start
seeing, hey, wow,
we get these amazing
numbers super quickly.
And they start to kind of--
like it's like a thread in a
sweater that just sort of pulls
more and more, more
and more into it.
And then eventually the
data warehousing team
is like, hey, all our
data is there already,
why don't we just move
the rest of our workloads?
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think one of the things
you gentlemen have mentioned
earlier was just this idea
of just the massive amounts
of data.
And it starts to make sense
that, for organizations, it's
easier to have all
your data in one place
and then to start
to do analytics.
And so that's
definitely another push.
SUDHIR HASBE: Just
one more thing, just
in that same realm-- so this
is exactly why, from a product
perspective, we have invested
in data transfer service.
So if you think about
it, a lot of customers
spend a lot of money with
Google on advertising
and different things.
And our thing was, this is a
completely different audience.
It's not a data
warehousing audience,
but it is the
marketing analysts that
need to go in and analyze their
spend, optimize their spend.
How do you do better
for marketing analytics?
And so we basically launched
data transfer service was like,
hey, with a few clicks, you
can get your AdWords data,
DoubleClick data, all of
this data into BigQuery
and then you can analyze it.
We have seen amazing amount
of adoption for this.
Customers who are not
traditionally GCP customers,
knowing this, they're like,
OK, let me with a few clicks
pull data in, start
analyzing it, visualizing it.
They're creating these
reports in Data Studio,
sharing it across
the organization.
And suddenly, as
Jordan was saying,
you get this whole
community started
forming in organizations
that started using it
and then it pulls
through the whole thing.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: OK, great.
Again, guys, we have
a couple of mics,
so if you have any questions
or if you have any comments,
just feel free to come
to one of the mics.
OK, so we'll switch gears
again just a little bit.
I think one of the things that
I've heard in this conference
over and over again
is this idea of just
open source and open
source architecture, right?
And just, Sudhir,
quickly, what are
you hearing from our customers
about open source technologies
and how are they appreciating
what Google Cloud is doing?
SUDHIR HASBE: Yeah, I think
open source is super critical.
As I talk to customers,
this ability-- just because
of hybrid and
multi-cloud scenarios,
ability for them to run their
workloads across and having
that option of running
them anywhere else
is super important for them.
This is why, as I was saying,
our investment in Beam
is so important
for our customers.
They love DataFlow.
Once customers come,
start leveraging DataFlow
for large-scale data processing,
I hope they never go away.
But that option
always exists, as hey,
with Beam being open
source and runners being
available in different engines,
they can actually do that.
So that's super
important for them.
It resonates really
well with CIOs and all.
Now similarly, as I was
saying, a lot of customers
already have huge deployments
of Hadoop Spark on premises.
Airflow-- Airflow is an amazing.
Composer, its very
fascinating for me.
Composer, in its private beta
or private alpha we had--
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Private alpha.
SUDHIR HASBE: Private alpha--
it was like 1,000 customers.
I have no idea how products
get to 1,000 customers
with being private.
But it was because
Airflow, which
is like the orchestration
tool, Apache Project,
everybody loved it already.
So we just enabled
that on the platform,
and that option was crazy.
So there's just supporting open
source, being an open cloud,
enabling experiences
that can come
from those is super
important for organizations.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Yeah, and
Composer GA'd, is that correct?
SUDHIR HASBE: Yeah, we
launched Composer to GA now.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY:
Yeah, we'd love
to hear your thoughts,
Matt, on just open source
and open source technology.
MATT ASLETT: Yeah, absolutely.
I actually-- so I
joined 451 Research
about 10 and bit years ago.
If I can remember that far.
And actually, at that time,
we had an open source practice
because open source was
relatively new and different.
And a lot of
companies were still
trying to figure
out what it meant.
And so we would work with
clients, both on the enterprise
side and the vendor side, just
to help them figure that out.
Obviously, over time, it
became more normalized,
and it's just part
of everything we do.
But what's been fascinating
is, over that time,
to see the approach
to open source change.
I mean, people used
to say you wouldn't
get fired for buying IBM.
Now I definitely think
now it's you wouldn't get
fired for buying open source.
It's that insurance policy
that organizations have.
And then most of the engagement
we do with the clients,
when they're looking at
different products and vendors,
it's not always a deal breaker,
but it's always up there
in the mix, like
where they would
default to open if they can.
And actually, I
had a conversation
with a Google Cloud
customer the other day
here, which proved
the value of that.
I can't say who it was, but
they're a very happy Google
Cloud customer.
But for one reason or another,
their Stackdriver costs
suddenly went absolutely
through the roof.
And so what they decided to do
was, just for a brief period,
while they figure
out what's going on,
stop that, switch
to open source.
Obviously, they had the
skills to be able to do this.
But they could do that.
They could just switch to
open source, do it themselves,
because it's open source.
It's a one-off thing.
They'll probably go back to
using the hosted version.
But it just was that benefit
that gives people the choice
to change how they deploy and
manage that, depending on what
whatever happens in the future.
And it's a little bit of an
insurance policy basically.
ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]